defeated by 230 votes the largest defeat
in the history of our democracy the
first government to be defeated by more
than 200 votes in indeed the government
itself could barely muster more than 200
votes last week they lost a vote on the
finance bill that's what's called supply
yesterday they lost a vote by the
biggest margin ever
that's what's regarded as confidence by
any convention of this house by any
precedence loss of confidence and supply
should mean they do the right thing and
resign mr. speaker the Prime Minister
has consistently claimed that her deal
which has now been decisively rejected
was good for Britain workers and
businesses if she is so confident of
that if she genuinely believes it
she should have nothing to fear from
going to the people and letting them
decide in this week in 1910 the British
electorate went to the polls they did so
because Herbert Asquith Liberal
government had been unable to get lloyd
George's people's budget through the
House of Lords they were confident in
their arguments and they went to the
people and they were returned to office
and it's still how our democracy works
when we have a government that cannot
govern in the absence of a written
constitution it is these conventions
that guide us if the government cannot
get if a government cannot get its
legislation through pub if it's
government if a government cannot get
its legislation through
it must go to the country for a new
mandate and that must apply when it is
on the key issue of the day the leader
of the Opposition engaging in a piece of
shameless political opportunism
[Applause]
which puts which puts party interests
ahead of national interest and isn't he
simply trying to disguise the fact that
on this great issue he has no policy
mr. speaker in 2017 the Prime Minister
and her party thought they could call an
election they would win it they thought
they'd returned an overall majority and
there was an enormous indeed the biggest
since 1945 increase in the Labour vote
during that campaign when people saw
what our policies actually were so mr.
speaker when the Prime Minister asked to
be given a mandate that's what she did
she bypassed the fixed term Parliament
act which was as my right honourable
friend the shadow foreign secretary
pointed out designed to give some
stability to the Tory Lib Dem coalition
government to ensure that the Lib Dems
couldn't hold the Conservatives to
ransom by constantly threatening to
collapse the coalition the fixed term
Parliament act was never intended to
prop up a zombie government and there
can be no doubt that this is indeed a
zombie government
the brave honorable German if he's
successful in this motion this evening
there may be a generation in a few short
weeks and that Labour Party manifesto
will this state whether they will be a
party of brixon or a party against
flexor it's a simple question what is
the answer
[Applause]
mr. speaker we are a democratic party
and our party will decide what policy we
fight the election our
but in the meantime we are very clear
there has to be a customs union there
has to be access to European trade and
markets there has to be a protection of
Rights there has to be a rejection of a
No Deal prexy and as I was saying mr.
speaker last week this government became
the first for more than 40 years to lose
on a finance bill and a shocking first
for this government
a shocking first it forced a heavily
pregnant member of this house
my friend the member perhaps Tintin
kilburn to delay a scheduled caesarian
to come to vote all because of their
cynical breaking of trusted pairing
arrangements I think we need to examine
that and examine our procedures to
ensure such a thing can never happen
again in the water and a Seabury mr.
speaker could you assist the house
please this is an important matter
I say this as a woman but we need to
establish once and for all was the
Honourable lady offered a pair all
reminds me that's not a point of order
my understanding is that there was a
pairing opportunity
[Applause]
my order order but my understanding is
that there was a pairing opportunity but
the issue was aired in the chamber on
Monday and again yesterday the right
honourable gentleman TV opposition is
absolutely entitled to highlight his
concern about this matter which I know
is widely shared but it should not be
subject now to further points of order I
hope with that satisfy Sir Jeremy Corbyn
thank you thank you mr. speaker
nothing demonstrates the sheer
incompetence of this government quite
like the brexit negotiations yesterday's
historic and humiliating defeat was the
result of two years of chaos and failure
it's now clear this government is not
capable of winning support for its core
plan on the most vital issue facing this
country the Prime Minister has lost
control and the government has lost the
ability to govern within two years
they've managed to turn a deal from what
was supposed to be I remember this very
well one of the easiest in human history
into a national embarrassment in that
time we've seen the Prime Minister's
demands quickly turned into one
humiliating climb down after another
brexit ministers have come brexit
ministers have gone but the shambles has
remained unchanged culminating in an
agreement which was described by one
former cabinet minister as and I quote
the worst of all worlds let's be clear
the deal the Prime Minister wanted this
Parliament to support would have left
the UK in a helpless position facing the
choice of either seeking and paying for
extended transition period or trapped in
the backstop
the Prime Minister may claim the
backstop would never come into force no
I'm sorry
there are order there are courtesies in
this place a member who seek to
intervene he or she should not do so out
of frustration by shrieking an
observation across the floor well
whether we say shriek or yell or bellow
or shout it was very noisy and it was
disorderly and the right honorable John
Rose I hold him in the highest regard I
have great affection for him but he must
behave better yes but who takes and it
whether an intervention is taken on our
no there's no alright about it I say to
the right honourable gentleman the
person who has the floor decides whether
to take an intervention that's life
that's the reality that's the way it has
always been Jeremy Corbyn Thank You mr.
speaker but who has confidence in this
government's ability to negotiate a
future trade deal with the EU by
December 2020
after shambles we've all witnessed over
the past two years this Frankenstein
deal is now officially dead and the
Prime Minister is trying to blame
absolutely everybody else
and we turn to be in modern British
history Prime Minister's when faced with
even a fraction of the Titanic and
calamitous margin that was faced by the
Prime Minister's yesterday they have
done the right and honorable thing
resigned and cooled a general election
word my right honourable friend agree
that in the pursuit of power and in the
trappings of office that she has now
forgotten what is right and honorable I
thank my friend for the intervention as
I made it very clear all the precedents
are that when a government's had the
defeat that this government has had its
time to resign and allow the people to
elect a new Parliament to deal with the
issues facing this country mr. speaker
let me be clear
the blame for this bare slice firmly at
the feet of the Prime Minister and a
government which time after time has
made hollow demands and given what
turned out to be false promises they say
they want this Parliament to be
sovereign yet when their plans have come
up against scrutiny they've done all
they can to obstruct and evade the Prime
Minister's original plan was to push
through a deal without the appropriate
approval of this Parliament only to be
forced forced into holding a meaningful
vote by the courts and by members of
this house to who I pay tribute for
ensuring we actually got the meaningful
vote last night in this house yes
I'm grateful to the leader of the
Opposition for giving way as I
understand that he will allow his party
to decide whether or not he will deliver
breaks that should he become Prime
Minister his party has already decided
that if he is not successful in getting
a general election he should support a
people's vote if he does not win the
vote tonight will he then support
that's host to give us a people's hoard
I'm sure the member is fully aware of
the decision made by my party's
conference that as the next phase of it
all options are on the table including
the option of that he has referred to I
give away to my friend at the back would
my honorable friend confirm whether in
this national crisis the Prime Minister
has telephoned the leader of the
Opposition to ask for a meeting to
discuss the way forward for our country
I haven't had such a call as yet mr.
speaker
I have my I have my phone mr. speaker
I think we should receive with this
debate I think we should proceed with
this debate the Prime Minister's
original plan original plan was to push
through a deal without approval as I
pointed out and forced into it by the
courts but since losing its majority in
the 2017 general election the government
has had numerous numerous opportunities
to engage with others and listen to
their views not just here in Westminster
below across the country their whole
framing of the EU withdrawal bill was
about giving excessive power to the
Secretary of State for brexit at the
expense of Parliament it was a bill that
Henry the eighth's would have been very
proud of yesterday's decisive defeat is
the result of the Prime Minister not
listening ignoring businesses unions and
members of this house
she has wasted two years recklessly
ploughing on with her doomed strategy
and even when it was clear even when he
was clear that a botched and damaging
deal a botched a damaging deal could not
remotely command support here or across
the country she decided to waste even
more time by pulling the meaningful vote
on December the 11th on the empty
promise and it was an absolutely empty
promise of obtaining legal assurances on
the backstop another month wasted before
the house could come to its decision
last night
some on the government side have tried
to betray the Prime Minister's approach
as stoical Mr Speaker what we've seen
over the past few months is not stoical
what we've witnessed is the Prime
Minister acting in her narrow party
interest rather than the public interest
her party her party is fundamentally
split on this issue
fundamentally split Mr Speaker when less
than 200 of their own MPs would be
prepared to support the Prime Minister
last night this constrains the Prime
Minister so much that she simply cannot
command a majority in this house and on
the most important issue facing this
country without rupturing her party and
it for this reason
this reason the government can no longer
govern yesterday the Prime Minister
shook her head when I said that she had
treated brexit as a matter only for the
Conservative Party yet within a half an
hour of the vote being announced the
Honourable member for Grantham and stump
and Stanford commented she is conducted
the argument as if this was a party
political matter rather than a question
of profound national importance how
right he was
how wrong she was to threaten him before
the vote took place I know many people
mr. speaker across the country will be
frustrated and deeply worried about the
insecurity around brexit but if this
divided government continues in office
the uncertainty and risks can only grow
a leading opposition for giving way when
those cross party talks start would he
tell the house which of the scarlet
pimpernel will come the lead of the
Opposition who campaigns for remain in
London and the South East or the leave
the opposition who campaigns for brexit
up north we need to know mr. speaker
there has been no offer of all party
talks there has been no communication on
all party talks all the prime minister
said was she might talk to some members
of the house that isn't reaching out
that isn't discussing it that is not
recognizing the scale of the defeat they
suffered last night a mr. speaker it's
not just over brexit that the government
is failing dismally letting down the
people of this country there has been
there has been a wind rush scandal the
shameful denial of Rights the detention
and even deportation of our own citizens
the government's flagship welfare policy
Universal Credit is causing real and
worsening poverty across this country
and just yesterday under the cover of
the brexit vote they sneaked out changes
that will make some pensioner households
thousands of pounds worse off
those changes build on the scourge of
poverty causing measures inflicted on
the people of this country including the
bedroom tax the two-child limit the
abominable rape Clause the outsource and
deeply flawed work capability assessment
the punitive sanctions regime and the
deeply repugnant benefit freeze people
across this country mr. speaker whether
they voted leave or whether they voted
remain know full well that the system
isn't working for them if you're up
against it you voted remain and you're
up against it and you voted for leave
this government doesn't speak for them
doesn't represent them and cannot
represent them food bank use has
increased almost exponentially and more
people are sleeping on our streets and
numbers have shamefully swelled every
year the Conservative Party used to call
itself the party of home ownership they
now called the party of homelessness in
this country
care is being denied to our elderly with
Age UK estimated age ookay estimating at
1.2 million older people not receiving
the care they need
7 billion cut from the adult social care
budgets in the past nine years ah NHS is
in crisis waiting time targets at
accident emergency I'm talking about
waiting times an accident emergency
departments and for cancer patients that
have not been met since 2015 and they've
never been met under the government of
this Prime Minister not yet the NHS has
endured the longest funding squeeze in
its history
leaving it short-staffed to the tune of
100,000 and NHS trusts and providers in
over 1 billion in deficit the human
consequences are clear life expectancy
is now going backwards in the poorest
parts of our country and stagnating
overall this is unprecedented
another shameful first for this
government another reason this
government should no longer remain in
office and why this motion of
no-confidence is so important
[Applause]
mr. speaker the leader of the Opposition
is making some powerful arguments not
very well but he's making arguments I
don't know if he could help us stay with
this I saw an opinion poll at the
weekend if there was any merit in his
arguments could he explain to the house
why it is that this party's six points
ahead in the polls could it be that it's
because he's the most hopeless leader of
the Opposition that we've ever had
I think the member
I thank the member for roxtor for her
intervention
I look forward to testing opinion in a
general election we'll be able to elect
Labour government in this country
I'm very grateful to my honorable friend
he's right to put on record current
concerns about uncertainty in the
country and absolutely right to talk
about poverty can he confirm that it is
the position of the British Labour Party
to rule out a No Deal brexit and can he
understand why the party that claims to
be the traditional party of business
won't do the same I can absolutely
confirm that we have voted against a No
Deal brexit apparently a business
secretary thinks that's a good idea
the Prime Minister was unable to answer
my question on this during Prime
Minister's question time
No Deal breaks it would be very
dangerous and very damaging for jobs and
industry all across this country I know
one more time I thought my honourable
friend and he's absolutely right under
this government we see our NHS in crisis
education under funded and our
communities have been devastated through
their austerity agenda more people
homeless more people living in poverty
more people using food banks if they
disagree with that why don't they call a
general election
I thank my friend for that intervention
and for his work representing his
constituency on this side of the house
we're determined to force this
government to accept the reality of the
defeat last night and forced his
government to go to the people so that
they can decide whether they want a
compartir in office that promotes
inequality poverty and injustice in
Britain or the labor alternative which
is bringing people together
however they voted in the referendum I
know some members of this house are
skeptical and members of the public I
believe could be also described as
skeptical but I truly believe that a
general election would be the best
outcome for this country as the Prime
Minister pointed out in his speech
yesterday both the Labour Party and
conservative party stood on manifestos
that accepted the results of the
referendum surely any government would
be strengthened in trying to negotiate
brexit by being given a fresh mandate
for the people to follow their chosen
course I know many people at home will
say well we've had two general elections
and a referendum in the last four years
and for the people of Scotland it's two
UK wide elections one Scottish
parliamentary election and two
referendums in five years so well Brenda
from Bristol might gasp not another one
spare a thought for Bernie from Butte
but mr. speaker the scale of the crisis
means we need a government with a fresh
mandate a general election can bring
people together focus on all the issues
that actually unite us the need to solve
the crisis in our NHS our children's
schools and our care for the elderly and
we all have a responsibility to call out
abuse and that has become too common
that mr. speaker has become too common
whether that's the abusive members of
this house going whether that's abuse
members receive or the men abuse that is
order no apologies no mr. Morris
don't yell from a sedentary position
like that if you seek to intervene you
seek to do so in the usual way that's
the only way to do it just because
you're angry doesn't justify you
behaving in that way stop it
Jeremy Corbyn Thank You mr. speaker mr.
speaker I'm sure we can all unite I'm
sure we can all unite we can all unite
in condemning racist abuse in any form
whatsoever within our society
[Applause]
and to many of our constituents have
faced that since the toxic debate in the
last referendum and if I may say so the
government's hostile environment
policies on the Windrush generation mr.
speaker many media pundits and members
of this house say there is currently no
majority in this house for a general
election let the members of this house
decide but Mr Speaker it's clear there
is no majority for this government's
brexit deal and there is no majority
either for a No Deal I want to pay
tribute to all members of this house who
like the Labour frontbench
are committed to both opposing the Prime
Minister's bad deal which we voted down
last night and ruling out the Curtis
catastrophe of no deal but I do believe
that following the defeat of the
government's plan a general election is
the best outcome for this country as the
Labour Party conference agreed last
September a general election mr. speaker
would give new impetus to negotiations a
new prime minister with a new mandate
and not just to break the deadlock on
brexit but to bring fresh ideas to the
many problems faced by our constituents
the problems that people face such as
very low pay and insecure work of inward
poverty which is increasing the problems
of trying to survive on universal credit
and living in deep poverty this the
scandal of inadequate social care which
might not concern the member opposite
but it does concern millions of people
around this country the crisis mr.
speaker in facing local authorities
health services and schools starved of
resources the housing and the
homelessness crisis where so many of our
fellow citizens have no roof over their
head night after night they are looking
to Parliament they're looking to
Parliament but for them a better and
fairer society is the Honourable general
just pausing it yes it quite right
absolutely very reasonable very sensible
thank you point of order
mark Francois okay is it not
well give me give me a go is it not
often the practice in this house but if
someone speaking from the despatch-box
refers to another member and challenges
them they then normally take it into
Mitch come on place but it is not in any
sense of Liggett ory commonplace but not
obligatory Jeremy Corbyn Thank You mr.
speaker mr. speaker if the house backs
this motion today then I welcome the
wide-ranging debates we'll have for the
future of our country and the future of
our relationship with the European Union
with all the options on the table as I
said before mr. speaker a prime minister
confident of what she describes as a
good deal and committed as she claims to
tackling burning in justices should have
nothing to fear from such an election
well mr. speaker if the house does not
back this motion today then surely it's
incumbent on all of us to keep all the
options on the table to rule out the
disastrous No Deal and offer a better
solution than the Prime Minister's deal
which was so roundly defeated yesterday
mr. speaker this government cannot
govern and cannot command the support of
Parliament on the most important issue
facing our country every single previous
Prime Minister in this situation would
have resigned and called an election it
is the duty of this house to show the
lead where this government has failed
and pass a motion of no confidence so
that the people of this country can
decide who their MPs are and who their
government is and who will deal with the
crucial issues facing
the people of this country I commend my
motion to the house
question is this house has no confidence
in Her Majesty's Government the Prime
Minister
mr. speaker last night the House
rejected the deal the government has
negotiated with the European Union today
it is asked a simpler question should
the next step be a general election I
believe that is the worst thing we could
do it would deepen
[Music]
[Applause]
would it were deepened division when we
need unity it would bring chaos when we
need certainty and it would bring delay
when we need to move forward so I
believe this house should reject this
motion
at this crucial moment in our nation's
history a general election is simply not
in the national interest Parliament
decided to put the question of our
membership of the European Union to the
people Parliament proposed to abide by
the result promised to abide by the
result Parliament invoked article 50 to
trigger the process and now Parliament
must finish the job that's what the
British people expect of us and speaking
to my constituents and to voters right
across the country that is what they
demand I will give way in and just in a
moment that is what they demand but a
general election would mean the opposite
far from helping I will just far from
helping Parliament finish the job and
fulfill our promise to the people of the
United Kingdom it would mean extending
article 50 and delaying brexit for who
knows how long Prime Minister Montgomery
she's lost a quarter of her cabinet 170
members of her back page what her gone
she's experienced the biggest defeat in
parliamentary history portrayed of
credibility has a government got left
for goodness sake Prime Minister won't
you just go
right on gentlemen might not have
noticed that what we're debating today
is a vote of no-confidence in the
government he has his opportunity to
express his opinion in that vote as
someone who was only defeated last night
by 230 votes may I encourage may I
encourage the prime minister to KBO and
never tire of reminding the country that
our good economic and one nation record
will be put at risk by a very extreme
left-wing and high taxation party
guy says my humble friend he is
absolutely right I will speak about this
later in my speech but it is over the
last years since 2010 with conservatives
in government that we've been able to
turn this economy around to fight in
short jobs who provided for people and
give people a better future
give me way I totally agree with the
Prime Minister that a general election
would solve nothing it's merely a
tactical device by the opposition to
close chaos but would she also agree
with me that one thing we also need to
rule out is a second referendum
[Music]
which would be highly divisive and would
not resolve the issues that we currently
face absolutely right and there's a
general election would cause the sort of
delay that I've just been talking about
but he is also right we had a referendum
in 2016 I believe it is incumbent on
this Parliament to deliver on the result
of that referendum and to deliver brexit
and as regards those issues the choices
we face as a country won't change our
after four or five weeks of campaigning
for a general election there's no
indication it would solve the dilemma we
now face not only I will be framed my
own offender not only is the no
guarantee an election would deliver a
parliamentary majority for any single
course of action I thank the Prime
Minister for giving way unlike some she
is clearly not afraid to debate
it is not exactly a secret that on
European policy
she and I have not seen entirely I - I
and it is possible
sighs everybody oh sorry
and it is possible we will continue to
disagree but I'm a conservative first
and last and I know opportunism when I
see it so can I tell her when the bells
ring the whole of the ERG will walk
through the lobbies with her to vote
this nonsense now
when I think can I thank my honorable
friend for his intervention and I know
what he said I'm happy to carry on
discussing with him different views that
we have had on the European issue but it
is absolutely clear that what the right
honourable gentleman the leader of the
Opposition is trying to do is not going
to help to resolve the issue of ensuring
that we deliver on brexit for the
British people I give way to honourable
lady I thank the Prime Minister for
giving way in 2017 she went to the
country and asked the country for a
mandate
she lost her majority last night she
asked the house to back her deal she saw
the biggest defeat for a government vote
in the history of this house last night
she said she wanted to open dialogue
with the whole of this house and yet she
has refused to open that dialogue with
the front bench does she not agree with
me that this looks like more of a
strategy to divide and conquer rather
than take this house and the country
together and work out how we move
forward
[Applause]
there's a to the honorable lady of what
I said last night was that we would be
open opening discussions having
discussions across this house there are
many different opinions on the issue of
how to deliver brexit across this house
there are some views not to deliver
brexit across this house I believe we
should be delivering brexit for people
what I made clear was that the first
priority should the leader of the
Opposition put a motion of no-confidence
down would be to debate that motion of
no-confidence I am confident that the
government will retain the confidence of
this house and when that happens I will
set further set out the further steps we
will take on discussions with members
Crossley's if members will just be a
little patient I have taken a number of
interventions I will make a little
progress but I will be generous in
taking interventions I think members
know from the number of hours I have
spent in this house answer
but I am Not Afraid to answer questions
from members
but mister but what we see when we look
I will in just a moment I'm your general
listen to what I said just help
sometimes we do not even know we do not
even know what position the Labour Party
would take on brexit in an election now
it's barely 18 months barely 18 months
since this country almost would just
look now me want it's barely 18 months
since this country last went to the
polls an election where well over 80
percent of voters almost 27 million
people backed parties whose manifestos
promised to deliver brexit that's what
the government intends to do that's
what's in the national interest not the
disruption delay and expense of a fourth
national poll in less than four years I
could wait wonderful thank you I thank
the Prime Minister for giving away to me
does she not agree with me that if the
leader of the Opposition himself wrote
on a note exactly what he wanted passed
it to the Prime Minister the Prime
Minister adopted that he would still
vote against it
my honourable friend my old friend is
absolutely right because of course the
position that the leader of the
Opposition took was the however good a
deal for the United Kingdom the
government brought back he would vote
against it however bad a deal the EU
offered he would vote for it so he has
no real national interest in getting the
right I thank the Prime Minister for for
giving way and my rather friend the
leader the opposition is absolutely
right to call for a general action today
because it's not just the government's
record on brexit which is at stake
tonight and I want to answer the
promised a direct question is she surely
saying that her record on policing and
crime is one that she's willing to stand
on because we have seen over twenty
thousand police officers cut since 2010
we see rising crime we see rising knife
cream and we seemed money money being
diverted money being diverted instead of
playing for police paying for a no deal
brags it which nobody in this house
wants to see happen of course we put
more money in to make more money
available to peace forces what did the
Labour Party do the neighbour voted
against
against
I will just I will just make a little
more progress than I will take some more
interventions now last night the house
did indeed speak clearly and I heard the
message that they sent I heard the
concerns of my colleagues and from
across the house and I understand them
and as I told the house last night if
the government secures and I've just
repeated if the government secures the
confidence of this house then my first
priority will be to hold meetings my
colleagues with our confidence and
supply partners the DUP and with senior
parliamentarians from across the house
our principles are clear a deal that
delivers a smooth and orderly exit
protecting our union giving us control
of our borders laws and money and
allowing us to operate an independent
trade policy these are what deliver on
the will of the British people under
great Hamilton I tried this with her out
there during during Question Time so I'm
gonna give her one more chance which of
the red lines which of the red lines
that she said that caused the defeat
that she had last night is she willing
to compromise on to get the agreement
through and the honorable gentleman will
not be surprised to hear that I will
give him the same answers I've just
given in my comments because what the
honourable gentleman I think what I
would point out to the honourable
gentleman is that the key thing that
this house needs to do that this
Parliament needs to do is to deliver
brexit for the British people that is
what we need to do and we need to do
both in a minute we need to deliver a
brexit that actually respects and
reflects the vote that was taken in the
2016 referendum I will give way to the
Honourable gentleman's come back in an
antiquated way on the friend I'm trying
to be helpful to the prime minister
believer or not
this is pure robotic fantasy it's hot
deal that has to change
and the deal as a product of the red
lines so when she has that meeting with
my right honourable friend which of the
red lines is she willing to give up on
and I repeat that we will approach these
discussions in a constructive spirit we
want to hear the detail from the house
of what it is that they want to see such
that we can secure the support of a
house for a deal I could wait while
moving my friend for giving away unlike
the leader of the Opposition does she
share my concerns that too many people
in this house are trying to scupper the
mandate given to us by the British media
for centuries for centuries this house
has taken arbitrary power from kings and
queens and peers and Grandy's and has
put that power in this house with a
public good but we now appear to be
becoming that arbitrary power that is
taken away and removing that mandate
that we gave the British people whose
rights to deliver on that mandate and to
protect and preserve a democracy
but my honourable friend puts his point
very powerfully indeed this Parliament
voted to ask the British people to say
to them it is your decision not tell us
what you think and we might think
afterwards whether or not we like it it
was it is your decision and we will act
on that decision and what we want to do
is I will just make a little more
progress if honorable members and right
honourable members will then the that is
what we want to do deliver on the will
of the British people as I said our
approach the meetings in a constructive
spirit focusing on ideas that are
negotiable and have sufficient support
in this house and the aim is to identify
what will be required to secure the
backing of the house and if these if
just a we'll just make a little more
progress I have been already generous in
interventions
and if these talks bear fruit as I said
earlier in Prime Minister Sir questions
they would be in no doubt I will go back
to Brussels and communicate them clearly
to the European Union and that's what
members asked for the leader of the SNP
MP said we should have talked with all
the leaders of the opposition parties
and work together in all our interests
the chairman of the brexit Select
Committee said if the deal was defeated
I would like to think that she would
take a bold step that she would reach
out across the house to look for a
consensus and that's exactly what I
propose to do so I can I say i I think
it would be now I think it would be a
little strange for them to vote against
that approach later today I'm in favor
of a general election who would make
that process of reaching out across
Parliament impossible I'll give way to
the Honourable the Honourable lady who
has been standing several times I thank
the Prime Minister for generosity in
giving way but with all due respect her
she's come to the House today after
suffering a very very large defeat
indeed with the same lines
absolutely and she's making the same
assertions as she was making before the
folks like never happening Street
spokesperson said that any discussions
would have to do start to proceed from
the red lines that she established
herself doesn't she realize in all
honesty now that the time has come for
her to show some flexibility and get us
into a genuine discussion rather than
just repeating the lines to take that
we've heard for the last
[Music]
what I am doing is setting out while the
British people voted for in the
referendum in 2016
[Music]
[Applause]
and that is our duty as a parliament to
deliver on that now I know that to serve
again I will just make a little progress
I know that the serving government in in
just a moment I know that the serving
government is a unique privilege the
people of this country put their trust
in you and in return you have the
opportunity to make this country a
better place for them adjusting in a
moment when I became Prime Minister and
that is what I pledge to do yes to
deliver brexit but also to govern on the
side of working people right across the
country for whom life is harder than it
should be and to build on the progress
that have been made since 2010 I'll give
way the Honourable lady and then
tomorrow so the Prime Minister for
giving away the problem is the Prime
Minister seems to be talking as if she
lost by 30 votes yesterday refusal to
even consider changing any of her red
lines when the EU and Irish government
and others have made clear that the deal
she got was dependent on those red lines
is making this impossible it's her to
clarify is she saying she will rule out
in any circumstances a customs union I'm
saying that what I want to see is what
the British people voted for they want
to see
this is this is this is this is very
important they voted for an end to free
movement they voted for an independent
trade policy they voted they voted to
end the jurisdiction of the European
Court of Justice and it is incumbent on
this Parliament to ensure that we
deliver on that and I think we should
build on the progress I said if the [ __ ]
this will just allow me I did say to my
humble friend further I'm taken person I
would take I thank the Prime Minister
for a giving way she's being criticized
for setting and sticking to red lines
but though those red lines simply
represents the promises that were made
prior to the referendum
my own orphan that's the point I have
been making and repeating is that when
people voted to leave they voted for
certain things they voted to ensure that
we could have that independent trade
policy and that we would earn free
movement for example and accept our duty
to ensure we deliver those huh grateful
for them speaker I've asked many people
rather referendum why they voted on one
side or the other got a very wide range
of replies but I have to say no one has
ever told me they voted to leave in
order that we could leave the customs
union or that we should be able they
wanted us to erect trade barriers
between ourselves and the rest of Europe
as she's committed desire my entire
support her aim of keeping open borders
between ourselves and the rest of Europe
is it not the case that there's nowhere
in the world where two developed
countries in any populated area are able
to have an open border unless they have
some form of customs use my right
honourable and learned friend refers to
obviously that the various trees there
were various reasons why people voted to
leave the European Union but when they
were doing that I believe that they did
vote to ensure that we continue to have
a good trading relationship with our
nearest neighbors in the European Union
I want but also to improve our trading
relationships with others around the
world that is what we were searching for
that is what was in the political
declaration for the future that package
was not voted through this house last
night I now as I say will talk to
parliamentarians across the house to
determine where we can secure the
support of the house but while
delivering brexit is an important and
key element of government it is also
important that we build on the progress
made since 2010 and build this can lead
this country towards the brighter fairer
more prosperous future
it deserves and I know I'm not won't
take I'm going to get make some progress
before I take any further interventions
I believe that this government has a
record to be proud of a record that
demonstrates that our policies and
principles are more than words
in 2010 we inherited the gravest of
economic situations a recession in which
almost 3/4 of a million jobs were lost a
budget deficit of one pound borrowed for
every four pounds spent and a welfare
system that did not reward work but in
the nine years since thanks to the hard
work and sacrifice of the British people
we have turned this country
our economy is growing but deficit is
down by four-fifths the national debt
has begun its first sustained Paul for a
generation the financial burden left for
our children and grandchildren is
shrinking by the day that is a record to
be proud of
[Applause]
I thank the family of Prime Minister for
allowing me to intervene under her
leadership this government has become
the first in British history to be found
in contempt of Parliament it has become
the first in British history to lose by
more than 200 votes on a primary policy
matter homelessness has spiraled out of
control the usage of food banks has
risen exponentially and much more
besides
so surely it is now time to act with
humility and to do the right and
honorable thing and to resign and call a
general election the whole point of this
debate today is to determine whether
this house has confidence in the
government or whether it thinks there
should be a general election now I say
that our record is a record to be proud
of but I know it's not enough a strong
economy alone is not good it's no good
unless we use it to build a fairer
society one where wherever you are
wherever you live and at every stage of
your life you know the government is on
your side we're growing up we're growing
up you will get the best possible
education not because your parents can
afford to pay for it but because that is
what every local school provides where
your parents have a secure job to go to
the pay's of decent wage where they get
to keep more of the money they earn each
month that when you finish school you
know that you can go to university
whether or not your parents went or you
can have an apprenticeship but when you
want to buy your first home enough
houses are being built so that you can
afford to get a foot on the housing
ladder
but when you but when you want to get
married it doesn't matter whether you
fall in love with someone of the same
sex or opposite and when you have
children of your own you will be able to
rely on our world-class NHS that both
parents can share their leave to look
after their baby and when they're ready
to go back to work the government will
help with the costs of child care and
that when you've worked hard all your
life you will get a good pension and
security and dignity in your old age and
that is what this government is
I think I forgiving what I think I
forgiving why and I acknowledge that she
wants to paint her government in a good
picture but isn't it true that precisely
because a lot of people are unhappy
there also voted for brexit and isn't it
the case that we need to clarify with
the British people what exactly they
wait they voted for and need to put a
precise deal in front of the people and
not just make a general assumption why
people voted for braixen people also
voted for breakfast because they were
generally unhappy with the state of this
country so isn't it isn't it
the the case now we need to put a
precise brakes a deal in front of the
people so all people can say but
actually breaks up will make a
difference well the Honourable lady
might recall that when I became Prime
Minister I made exactly that point that
people in voting for exit there were
various reasons people voted for exit
but I do think for some they wanted to
change in the way politics delivered for
them I think that they were concerned
that they felt that politicians weren't
listening to them and that is precisely
why it is so important that on the
result of the referendum we listen and
we deliver - for the people of this
country and this government is
delivering in a whole range of ways I
thank the Prime Minister for giving way
and I appreciate the positive confident
and optimistic picture the future the UK
that she painted what a contrast for the
leader of the Opposition who takes every
opportunity to talk Britain down
somebody claims that they aspire to be
Prime Minister if they have such utter
lack of confidence in Britain and the
British people
anybody anybody who wants to be Prime
Minister should believe in this country
and believe
[Applause]
I know the Prime Minister thank you
thank you so much pick me around this I
know there's so little time to get in
all the achievements but on the same
note
[Applause]
may law but it is this government who is
taking the environment more serious
[Applause]
we are putting sustainability first and
that is more important even than brexit
because if we don't ever have the
environment and our record on this is
second to none
microbeads ancient water protection
cleaners we would be long
can I can I thank my honorable friend
she has indeed set out an area where
this government has been taking
important action I'd like to commend the
work that she's done on that and the
work of my right honourable friend the
Secretary of State in this area because
we are indeed leading the way on a
number of ways on this I will take I
will take my own take my honorable
friend and then I'm afraid I must make
some progress because the number of
people wants I'm very grateful to the
Prime Minister she is giving way
considerably more than the opposition
she's just mentioned the stewardship of
the NHS under her leadership would she
like to remind the lead of the
opposition that is this government that
has just pledged through the NHS
long-term plan 50 percent per annum more
funding that was pledged by him at the
last general election the biggest cash
boost to the NHS in its history a
long-term plan that ensures its
sustainability for the future that's
being delivered not by a Labour Party
but by the Conservatives
and if we will if honorable members if
honorable and right honourable members
will forgive me I am conscious that the
time is getting on and there will be
many members and the right I'll remember
for Exeter is encouraging me not to take
so many interventions and to get on with
the thing but we are building a country
that works for everyone but there is
there is much more to do
investing in our industrial strategy so
we're creating the jobs of the future in
all parts of our country not just in
London and the southeast delivering our
long term plan for the NHS but my rod on
remember has just referred to
so that friend is just referred to that
our most precious institution is
equipped for the future tackling the
lingering in justices but for too long
have blighted the lives of too many
people women being paid less than men
mental health being treated with the
same seriousness and resource and
physical health as physical health a
criminal justice system that as poorer
outcomes if you're black than if you're
white and an education system that has
left white working-class boys as less
likely to go to university than anyone
else these are issues we need to tackle
and the mission of this government will
not stop this is a government building a
country that is more prosperous a
country that is fairer and a country
that works for everyone
and with the confidence of this house we
will go on delivering for Britain driven
by a passionate belief in doing what is
right for our country and right for our
people actually not in self-interest but
in the national interest and that is the
simple mission that has underpinned our
approach to the brexit negotiations and
as we enter the next stage of that
process I have made clear I want to
engage with colleagues across the house
now the question now is whether the
Labour leadership will rise to the okay
but I fear the answer is no because as
the Labour leader himself has indicated
brexit is the biggest issue this house
in this country has faced for
generations what it demands from senior
politicians is responsible leadership
and pragmatic statement shape the leader
of the Opposition as yet has shown
neither is failure to set out a clear
and consistent alternative solution is
the third reason why this house should
comprehensively reject this motion
indeed the shadow brexit secretary has
described Labor's position on brexit as
one of constructive ambiguity
I think the shadow trade secretary
called it something slightly more
succinct but definitely not
parliamentary and therefore I cannot
repeat it but I call it not being
straight with the British people because
for more than two for more than two
years the leader of the Opposition has
been either unable or unwilling to share
anything other than vague aspirations
empty slogans and ideas with no
grounding in reality and when the
president of the European Commission
said Labour's brexit ambitions would be
impossible for the European Commission
to agree to the right honourable
gentleman simply shrugged and said
that's his view I have a different view
but I have to say well if my own will
just forgive me I have to say last night
just for a moment I thought that the
leader of the Opposition might surprise
us all because he told this house it was
not enough to vote against the
withdrawal agreement and that we also
have to be for something so surely that
was the moment that was the point at
which after months of demanding that I
stand aside and make way for him he was
going to reveal his alternative we
waited we waited but nothing came he
still faces both ways on whether labour
would keep freedom of movement and he
won't even be drawn on the most basic
point of all I referred him PM cues to
the fact that on Sunday when challenged
as to whether if there was a general
election he would campaign to leave the
European Union he refused to answer that
question five times he's refused to
answer that question
in response to members of this house
today the government has no doubt about
its position under this government the
United Kingdom will leave the European
Union I thank the Prime Minister for
giving way she's quite right to point
out the yawning chasm of the heart of
Labour's policy but the promise also
said we need to come up with a
constructive alternative and speaking to
colleagues around the house it strikes
me very powerfully that there is there
is one element of the currently proposed
deal which if changed would make it much
more likely to pass and that is the
backstop would the Prime Minister
therefore consider contacting the
European Commission's officials in the
coming days and over the weekend and
asked them to make legally binding
changes to that backstop which I believe
would then have a very good chance of
passing this house but can I say to my
honorable friends that the the purpose
of the various discussions we're going
to have is to identify is to identify
the issues that will secure the support
of this house and I will take those
issues to the European to the European
Parliament I will give way to the
honourable gentleman and then I am going
to make progress as others can speak in
this debate I am extremely grateful
taking away she has been generous she
has talked about engagement with this
house and yesterday she referred to this
house as the fulcrum of our democracy
can I gently point out that she is the
Prime Minister who went to the Supreme
Court to stop us having her having
engagement with this house and the vote
that we had yesterday was on the back of
an amendment that she herself oted
against she talks about engagement with
this house but we have experienced
nothing but hostility from the
going forward going forward will she put
her words into action if not she doesn't
deserve to have the job in the first
place can I say to the honorable
gentleman that I think he has been in
this house on many occasions when I have
come to listen to this house and have
taken questions and answered questions
from this house in fact in fact a whole
it advantage from October through to
December to a whole 24 hours spent
answering questions in this house but
vital though brexit is vital no brexit
is there's much more to being the Prime
Minister of the United Kingdom and that
is after all the job to which the right
honourable gentleman the leader of the
Opposition as FAR's and if I may just my
right honorable friend will just bear
with me I do just want to make some
progress I understand a significant
number of members have put in to speak
and by putting full with this motion the
right honourable gentleman asking this
house to accept that he could be the
next prime minister
so how would he have faced some of the
big challenges that I have faced over
this prime minister over the last two
and a half years when Russia when Russia
launched a chemical attack on the
streets of Salisbury I worked with our
allies to degrade Russian intelligence
capabilities and hold those responsible
to account his contribution was to
suggest that we asked Russia to
double-check the findings of our own
scientists
when the Syrian regime used chemical
weapons to murder innocent men women and
children in Duma I stood with our allies
to uphold the international consensus
that the use of chemical weapons should
not be tolerated he wanted to give an
effective veto on action to President
Putin and the Russian government the
very government that was supporting the
Syrian regime this is the leak the
leader of the party of aptly called for
the dismantling of nature but leader of
the party of Bevin says Britain should
unilaterally disarm herself and cross
our fingers that others follow suit the
leader of the party that helps deliver
the Belfast agreement invited IRA
terrorists into this Parliament
just weeks after their colleagues had
murdered a member of this
his leadership of the Labour Party has
been a betrayal of everything that party
has stood for the trial of the vast
majority of his MPs and a betrayal of
millions of decent and patriotic labour
voters and I look across the house and
see backbench members who spent years
serving their country and office in a
Labour government but I fear here that
today this is simply not that is simply
not a party that many of its own MPs
joined and if we want to see what he
would do to our country we can do no
better than look at what he has done to
his party before he became Labour leader
before he became labor leader nobody
could have imagined that a party which
had fought so hard against
discrimination could become the banner
under which racists and bigots
[Music]
[Applause]
but that is exactly what has happened
under the leadership of the right
honourable gentleman British Jewish
families who have lived here for
generations are asking themselves where
they should go if he ever becomes Prime
Minister that is what has happened under
the leadership of the right honourable
gentlemen what we've also seen is a
Jewish Labour MP who had to hire a
bodyguard to attend her own party under
the leadership of the right honourable
gentleman what he's done to his party is
a national tragedy what he would do to
our country would be a national calamity
very grateful Prime Minister for being
so generous and engaging in a debate and
as ever she could teach a few people
lessons on that can I just check Oh back
to the question or the intervention from
the Honourable member for ho ho
he makes if I may suggest a very
important point that whilst the Prime
Minister has been very generous mr.
speaker in coming to this place and
answering questions that complains is
that we have been excluded in a
meaningful way at the outset in helping
to determine the principles upon which a
brexit deal should be negotiated and for
many of us Prime Minister in seeking to
be true to the oath and the promises to
our constituents and voting for things
against our own government we've been
threatened with deselection
threats against our safety and even
death threats and I know how seriously
she takes that and I thank her for her
kindness last week in the note she sent
to me what she now make it clear to
anybody listening to all of this that we
hear especially on these benches but is
it applies also to vulnerable a right
honourable members opposite given the
very wise words and observations just
she's just made about the state of the
labour party that it would be wrong for
anybody to be intimidated or bullied in
any way at all simply for coming here
and being true to what they believe in
and what they believe is in the national
interest can I say to my right honorable
friend I think what she experienced I
think last week was appalling I
understand that she has experienced
other incidents more recently and can I
just say to her I absolutely agree
everybody in this house holds their
opinions and their views with passion
and commitment and it should be right
for everybody in this house to be able
to express those views with passion with
commitment and not feel that they are
going to be subject to intimidation or
harassment or bullying I think that is
very important I'm sure that is a
sentiment that commands approval across
the whole of this house and once again
I'm sorry to my right honorable friend
for the experiences that she has gone
through well I will give way to the
right oh gentle
on this point and then I am NOT I am
going to conclude and I'm grateful to
the prime minister but she must
recognize that she has built a cage of
red lines that produced a deal that was
overwhelmingly rejected by this house we
rejected the deal because we rejected
the cage now this afternoon she has
yielded nothing about how any single one
of those red lines will change if she is
not prepared to change how on earth
could we in this house continue to place
a shred of confidence in her - the right
honourable gentleman that first of all
the point I made last night the point
I've repeatedly made here today is that
I will be talking to people across this
house talking to my own colleagues
talking to the DUP talking to other
parties talking to there are different
groups of people within this house who
have different views on this issue and
hearing from people and finding what
will secure the confidence of this house
in terms of securing the support of this
house for the way in which we deliver
brexit but actually I noticed that
perhaps it was serendipity that I
allowed the right honourable gentleman
to intervene on me just at the point at
which I was going to say that if the
leader of the Opposition wins his vote
tonight what he would attempt to do is
indeed to damage our country and to
wreck our economy and of course it was a
right honorable gentleman who left that
note there is no
[Applause]
by mr. speaker was nice to honor a
Treasury tradition that went back to
Churchill with a text that is pretty
much the same but I was proud to be part
of a team that stopped a recession
becoming a depression
oh stop trying to shout other honorable
or right honourable members down calm
yourselves
Liam birth of course a member of the
party that backs labor spending plans
and she is the one who's presided over a
government that has doubled the size of
the national debt of course yes we did
see what was happening in terms of
financial crisis and the impact that had
but of course what had happened was that
a Labour government in a Labour Party in
government had failed to take the steps
to make sure that the party was in the
government country was in a position to
be able to deal with those issues what
would we see what would we see if we saw
labour win this vote tonight they would
wreck our economy they'd spread division
undermine our national security and as
we said earlier as I've said earlier on
the biggest question of our times he
provides no answers no way forward and
nothing but evasion contradiction and
political gains this house cannot and
must not allow it no I'm I'm about to
conclude so I'm not going to take any
more interventions we're living through
a historic moment in our nation's
history following the referendum that
divided our nation in half we dearly
need to bring our country back together
and last night's vote showed that we do
have a long way to go but I don't
believe a general election is the path
to do that and I don't believe that a
government led by the leader of the
Opposition is the path to do that either
we must find the answer among ourselves
in this house and with the confidence of
the house this government will leave
that process because this is the
government that has already delivered
record employment put more money in the
pockets of ordinary working people and
given the NHS the biggest cash boots
boost its ever received from any
government of any color this is the
government that is fighting the burning
in justices of poverty inequality and
discrimination that for too long have
blighted the lives of too many of our
people and it's the government that's
building a country that works for
everyone
and as we leave the European Union we
must raise our
sites to the kind of country we want to
be a nation that can respond to a call
from its people for change a nation that
can build a better future for every one
of its people a nation that knows
moderation and pragmatism are not dirty
words but are how we work together to
improve people's lives that's our
mission it's what we're doing and with
the backing of the house it is what we
will continue to do I'm proud of what we
have achieved so far I'm determined that
the work will go on
in that I know we have the confidence of
the country we now ask for the
confidence of this house reject this
motion
'i'm Blackford
thank you very much mr. speaker it is a
pleasure to follow the prime minister of
course I wish I know I will and if she
does choose to resign today can I wish
it all the best for a future career mr.
speaker in many respects this is not a
debate that we should be having if we
reflect on what happened last night
it is a government that brought its
brexit deal in front of parliament and
it lost by a majority of 230 mr. speaker
something which is quite unprecedented
and defeat from the government with her
own backbenchers and the opposition and
a united manner voting against this
government and if we go back just a
short few weeks to December of course
there was a motion of confidence in the
Conservative Party and in that situation
a majority of government backbenchers 14
against the Prime Minister and might be
saved when I go back and I listened to
the intervention for the vulnerable
gentlemen from really and Whitford he
said that the members of the ERG would
be going through the lobbies to support
the government tonight and this mr.
speaker that does indeed say at all it's
the ERG that has captured the Prime
Minister exactly and the real reality of
where we stand today is that when the
Prime Minister went to the United
Kingdom in an election in 2017 an
anticipation of getting a majority they
got a bloody nose and she came back as a
minority
you can only I will give way in a second
I would say
I would say to the government man Jesus
we just settle down a little you would
love to be in the possession let the
Scottish National Party Erin because we
have a majority of seats from the people
of Scotland I give away I thought
perhaps he could just inform the house
how many seats in Westminster how many
Westminster Abbey's did the SNP have
before the 2017 election and how many
they have often
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm very grateful to the triune Esther
for the intervention can I say to the
Prime Minister that our 59 seats in
Scotland the Scottish National Party
hold 35
we have only gave the election to the
Scottish Parliament since 27 mi the
Prime Minister could only dream of being
in a situation where she has a majority
but let's come back to the fundamentals
of this we have a prime minister that is
captured by a right-wing brexit ears
because the issue is when you have a
minority you have to be able to work
across party but we've got this thing
I'm not gonna say it but we've got the
situation that the Prime Minister has to
hold into the DUP but the DUP will only
support her and very certain
circumstances this is not just mr.
speaker about the defeat of the
government last night on brexit it is a
government that is stuck that can't get
its legislative program through it has
no majority support in this house it is
a government that it's passed this time
and if the government had any humility
had any self-respect it would reflect on
the scale of that defeat last night we
shouldn't be having this motion of
no-confidence the government should
recognize it has no moral authority the
government quite simply should go Jacob
Riis mod are right on war gentlemen for
giving way but I think his speech is a
little eccentric mr. speaker
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he seems to think that the ERG in the
dup controlled the Prime Minister why
why then did a hundred and twenty of us
vote against the Prime Minister
yesterday if we're in such control we're
clearly not doing it very well perhaps
let me explain
the Honorable gentlemen it's supporting
a motion of no-confidence against the
prime minister as he did clearly
expressed that he doesn't have the
confidence of the Prime Minister and
what the ERG is seeking to do is to make
sure that the government delivers what
they want which is a hard brexit we know
Theo brexit perhaps against the
interests of the majority of the people
in the United Kingdom but here's the
reality
I've been listened very carefully to
what the Prime Minister has said today
there is no change to the government's
position the Red Lions love legislators
and I fear that what is really going on
is that we have a government that is
seeking to run down the clock and the
knowledge that they have and I will in a
minute safe in the knowledge that they
withdraw all actors going through
seeking to drive Parliament to the
margins and to make sure that we do
crash out of the European Union with no
deal as a serious prospect all of us all
of us
Mr Speaker should recognise the risks of
New Deal that no sane person in this
house would support and the government
should unilaterally take that risk to
all of us and to all our constituents
off the table I happily give away like
my humble gentleman he must agree that
the Prime Minister is a record setter
record levels of poverty record levels
of homelessness and now and now record a
record defeat in majority that any
government has heard now maybe not in
our lifetime do you think that majority
will ever get beaten well I would I
would say to my honourable friend
because he is my honourable friend it's
a record level of lack of humility
see from this government is absolutely
right we have for ten years of austerity
from this government people are hurting
we can see that through the poverty
figures we can see it through the
forecasts of the increase in poverty
that will take place in their harsh
reality I have to say to the honourable
gentleman we know from the government's
own analysis that in any version of
brexit that the economy of the United
Kingdom will be weaker than it would be
obtained if we stayed in the European
Union that is the fundamental point to
this and I say respectfully to the Prime
Minister I understand the issue of
respecting l'avorton
2016 but when the government knows that
the economic circumstances of its
citizens are going to be negatively
affected we have a responsibility to say
to the people on the basis of the
information that we now have we have a
duty to go back to you because nobody
nobody mr. speaker irrespective of how
they voted in that referendum voted to
make themselves pure and I have to say
and I see it with respect to the inside
Minister that it is shameful that we are
not being honest with the people of this
country we need to waken up we need to
waken up and let's take the announcement
from Jaguar Land Rover I know there are
many reasons why Judge your Land Rover
are restructuring we know it's to do
with diesel cars we know it's to do with
China but at the same time Jack your
Land Rover made it absolutely crystal
clear that brexit is a fundamental issue
which is driving that restructuring no
government mr. speaker should wreck it
should be in the situation then it wants
to put unemployment on the table that
unemployment is a price worth paying
that's what happened under Thatcher and
this government at its peril would take
the risks with the economy and the
livelihoods of the people of the United
Kingdom
an honorable friend for giving away and
it's drawing not the time come for the
country to see that the Tory Party not
by their words but by their actions are
now enacting a policy of moving us
towards a No Deal breakfast I am very
very grateful from my dear and
honourable friend for that point because
I I have to say to this house and I have
to say to the people of the United can
do I am worried I am really worried
about what we are doing and the risk of
a No Deal is something which is and
think about it I need I need to make I'm
with with respect I know there are there
are many people that want to speak and I
do have to make progress I will take
interventions later on but we have to be
honest with people as to what these
risks are and I can say to this house
that we in Scotland want no part of it
if the government and the Prime Minister
wants to drive the bus over the cliff we
will not be in the passenger seat with
this government mr. speaker you know we
all will Fionn hear about the travails
of the European Union the nasty unified
Union but I can tell you as someone that
lives in the islands of Scotland that
the European Union has been fantastic
for our region
when I contrast the behavior of the
European Union with this government
people in the highlands a right to be
angry mr. speaker the European Union
agreed to give convergence uplift funds
to her farmers and crop tops on the
basis of the low level of financial
support that was in place a hundred and
sixty million pounds that should be
handed over to Scottish crafters and
whereas there are certain deities there
hasn't been handed over yet we're
helping the Secretary of State for
Scotland I could have sorted defending
the interest of Scottish farmers and
Scottish craft the Scottish farmers and
crafters there were PA heavy price for
brexit and the institution that's been
standing up wanting to support them is
not this house it's not this government
it's the European Union I know well Mr
Speaker I would like to thank first of
all for letting his party give me a CT
into this place but that is no
mr. speaker what the Bible remember says
it's quite correct it was a question
that I put to the plants yesterday which
is it so much in terms of infrastructure
projects would not have happened in my
constituency had it not been for
European money and this was crucial in
halting the terrible drain of our
brightest and best from the high level
to leave and never return home again
that I say mr. speaker is an issue that
is hugely important to me and it remains
as such like the Honorable gentleman my
sentiments the people of Caithness and
Sutherland that give him a secret
solution we all served with a good rule
and the ongoing support of our
constituents some things as anyone
should ever ever take for granted Mr
Speaker I want I do want to make
progress I apologize I have talked a bit
breaks if and I want to go on to it the
record of this government this the prime
minister talked about delivering a fear
of society oh my goodness those of us
that live in the highlands have been in
the pilot of universal credit the damage
which has been done to many of our
people in many of our communities I look
at my colleagues and these benches when
I look at my honourable friend from
Adrienne shorts the member for Glasgow
central they found a fit the member for
Inverness Nairn bagging or constrast be
that day after day week after week have
had to stand up and highlight the issues
with universal credit highlight the
issues with the rape clause highlight
the issues with a two-child their policy
and this government has simply not
listened to the damage that has been
done it's a government obsessed with in
bending accrue and hostile environment
for immigrants their families and their
children and a government that continues
to die deny the rights of 1950s women
when I first came into this house I was
the SNP pension spokesperson I lost
count of the number of debates that I
called and spoken highlighting the
injustice the millions of women faced
women that had worked all their life
when anticipation that there was a
contract between them and the state that
they would get their state pension women
in some cases were given as little as 14
months notice
that there pensionable age was going to
increase by as much as six years
that's the heartlessness and the cruelty
of this government that left many of
them in poverty because they ripped up
the contract that does mr. speaker
that's what it was between those
individuals and the state and I'm
appealed to the Prime Minister on many
occasions to write that right this
government could easily have put its
hands into the Treasury coffers the
National Insurance Fund sits at the
southwest and I would ask him does he
also agree with me that it is appalling
that this government has slept oh and
amongst all the news of brixon that are
making fun of changes to pensions and
that pensioners who have a partner under
there under the age of pensions they
will have to claim universal credit
instead that's good yeah my honourable
friend is correct and she's highlighted
what this government's been doing
sneaking these kind of announcements I
know that she is a Doty fighter for
pensioners as she will for young people
and we will stand up in this house for
those that are affected that way and I
will give me one more time
be grateful he said earlier is remarks
that he's worried about economic growth
and I quite understand that share that
those concerns but is he also therefore
worried that the scottie she can't
economic growth is slowing now growing
at half the rate of the rest of the UK
and what is his party doing about that
north of the border
all good grief and I have to say the the
honorable gentleman is mistaken that
what has happened over the course of the
last year that growth in Scotland has
overtaken Mater Dei you know mr. speaker
the majority of the controls of the
Scottish economy why you're set with the
Scottish government this set with the
Parliament you know in response we would
dearly love to have full control of her
destiny in Scotland because one of the
reasons that we desire independence is
because our economic interest simply
have not been looked after by
Westminster and I well you know training
gets great I vote in a second but let me
let me just say this when I look in the
rearview mirror and I look at Scotland
over the course of the last hundred
years our population has barely growing
generations of young people have had to
leave Scotland because of lack of
Economic Opportunity that's not the
Scottish government that's responsible
for that is her Westminster and I am
delighted that there's a report which
has come out from Highlands and Islands
Enterprise over the course of the last
few days for the first time the trend of
young people staying and living in the
highlands has turned around that's
because of the investment that the
Scottish government is putting in young
people
my challenges that we face on austerity
from this conservative government I'm
very greatly my right honorable friend
for forgiving way and I do hope that the
motion made by the leader of the
Opposition is successful this evening
today I believe I was reminded today is
the 100th kneel it's an anniversary from
1913 of the home rule Act the third one
with first home rule ads for Ireland
which was agreed for by this house but
defeated in the other place and in terms
of control yet again and that's with
Judith reference to the Democratic
Unionist Party are in control of the
government offices if the vote is
successful this evening can my right
honourable friend assure me that the
Scottish National Party will have no
truck with any government funding the
Democratic Unionist Party and their type
of politics
Robin there's a very simple answer to
that that it is yes of course
Mr Speaker I I have been generous and
taking interventions I need to move on
because I am I glanced at my notes I see
him only at page two and I'm sure that
want me to make some progress mr.
speaker this Prime Minister and the
Conservative government have let us
although Westminster once again has
proven that it can only lay it Scotland
own the Scottish National Party has no
confidence in the UK government mr.
speaker Scotland voted to the mean I
want to see it again the open 40 tonight
[Applause]
ministers talking about the national
interest
I've been asked the prime minister to
reflect on the fact that this is our
nation of Scotland any family of nations
going when we were told in 2014 that if
we stayed in the United Kingdom that our
right European citizens would be
respected what we find is that this
government completely ignores the which
is exactly of the Scottish people and
wants to drag us out to the UNEP in
Union against our rule to take away our
rights that we have as EU citizens mr.
speaker that can be no surprise that
they contempt Sean to Scotland by the
Tories over the past couple of years
have strengthened and reinforced the
case for Scotland to be an independent
mr. speaker it's coming every reasonable
attempt to compromise in to protect
Scotland's interest by the Scottish
government has been spurred the furs of
the Scottish Parliament have been eroded
this place is taken well I can I can
hear the scoffing from the Tory benches
but when the withdrawal Act went through
the SNP membership went up by ten
thousand the next day get the people of
Scotland know that the Secretary of
State for Scotland sat and there's
nothing as the furs of Scotland
overfishing
over farming woman agriculture the
environment were taken back against the
wishes of the Scottish government
or order the house is overexcited and
although the right honorable gentleman
is well able to look after himself he
must be heard sometimes there is a
concerted and excessively noisy apparent
attempt to interrupt and that should not
happen
Stuart Malcolm MacDonald they are a
curious Bunch mr. speaker class gasps my
right honourable Fred can I ask my right
honourable friend to deed all members
across the house to reflect on the fact
that in 2014 sure the Scottish people
voted to stay in the UK but two years
later but two years later they voted
Steen e you these two things are
fundamentally incompatible because of
the Prime Minister's desire to drag us
out so at some point at some point one
will have to give she might be able to
delay that but independence is
inevitable is it not
[Music]
can I just say to the Honorable
gentlemen it's coming yet for all that
yeah
mr. speaker well I know I'm gonna I will
see that she's not the circus right I
can I can hear from a 70 position then
this issue about whether we can demand a
referendum and simply say to the Tory
benches that you have to respect the
sovereignty of the people of Scotland
however you dress it up when the
Scottish National Party went to the
people of Scotland in 2016 we won the
elections on a mandate if there's a
material change of circumstances that we
may seek to have a referendum on
independence that is the majority a
Scottish Parliament Parliament and ever
voted for this house in July debated a
motion on the claim of right that
recognized the sovereignty of the
Scottish people this house accepted that
motion is right if and when the Scottish
government comes to Westminster an axe
for a say as for a section 30 agreement
this government should respect the
democracy and the sovereignty of the
Scottish people and allow it
mr. speaker Scotland will never never
not ever forget or but we would give the
utter contempt shown to our nation by
this Prime Minister and the government
mr. speaker the Prime Minister and her
government cannot escape the reality our
government has fled to political
collapse in this country hamstrung this
government is completely frozen in its
own failure we have reached the
dangerous in--this with the clock
ticking though we need to remove the
shambolic Conservative government extend
out the core 50 and yes give the people
of the United Kingdom a sea stunning
account of the current situation but
this he agree with me that this Prime
Minister has painted herself into this
corner she is going to have to give on
at least some of her red lines and it is
deeply regrettable that she has waited
till the eleventh hour to reach out
across the house and that history will
judge her on her deeds not her words I
absolutely agree and of course if I can
make the reflection that in Scotland we
do have a parliament which is elected by
proportional representation we are used
to minority governments we're used to
having to reach a consensus and indeed
if I look at the motion which was passed
by the Scottish Parliament on the issue
of Rexes it was supported by the
Scottish National Party by the Labour
Party by the Liberal Democrats by the
Greens prime minister that's how you do
it
and the Prime Minister in this house has
simply misunderstood the challenges of
trying to reach a consensus across
Parliament she is working with her own
brexit extremists and failing to work to
build a consensus
mr. Anthony I must be pointless I'm
serious mr. speaker as the Prime
Minister does survive today she must not
act extend out to 250 and legislate for
a people's vote no I I must turn to the
Labour Party the Scottish National Party
with the first table of motion of
no-confidence supported by others by the
Liberal Democrats white Camry and the
Greens
we asked for that to be debated before
Christmas know we knew yesterday that
the government was giving active
consideration now allowing had to be to
have that have that bought today on the
motion that was laid down by the
Scottish National Party and others the
Labour Party have been shamed into
bringing this motion a motion that we
should have discussed before Christmas I
welcomed that we are having this debate
to be able but on the basis of what
happens today
by a few to friends and colleagues in
the labor park that we have to work
together to hold this government to
account and if we are to do that then we
have to recognize the harm that brexit
is going to do to all our constituents
it is time for the leader of the
Opposition and I say respectfully to
them to recognize that there is no such
thing as he jobs first brexit that we
have to recognize that we want to
protect the interests of our citizens
then it has to be a people's vote we
don't have time these do get jobs when
we don't have time mr. speaker the
Labour Party have to join us and that
campaign today and I say this to the
leader of the Opposition all the young
people that voted labour in England and
2017 were between a price from the
Labour Party of Jeremy Corbyn does not
give that leadership so I say to the
leader of the Opposition get off that
fence come and join us take that
opportunity to the terrace once and for
all that labor will back the people's
vote forgiven we and he mentioned the
shame of the Labour Party
I wonder what he reflect in the shame of
the Scottish National Party in Edinburgh
on a day when College lecturers in
Scotland are striking when teachers in
Scotland are considering industrial
action when waiting lists are going up
under educational standards are going
down that is available in key government
in Scotland is he ashamed of that as
well
you know missus because she never said
the Honourable gentleman used to sit in
the Scottish Parliament if he wants to
debate devolve matters are suggested
tries day
the issue for you is have a very amiable
disposition mr. Kay but that you are
becoming a Mountie exuberant Dennison of
the house dare I say it even in your
conduct a tad to deploy the word used by
the Honorable North East Somerset
eccentric now calmed Zen restraint try
to cultivate the air of the elder
statesman in Blackford Thank You mr.
speaker I'm proud of the record of
investment of public services by my
government in Scotland but the situation
we face is austerity from Westminster
and we have taken the hard decisions on
the one hand to merely a Tory austerity
but also to invest in our public
services and it's there Tory colleagues
in the Scottish Parliament that want to
cut taxes that weren't too hard on
austerity that will damage the interests
of the people of Scotland
begone mister speak and I went to move
on and begin to conclude the people of
Scotland wish could have been in the
European Union we want a country of
opportunity a nation free from poverty a
country where immigrants are welcome and
where refugees are given refuge we want
a Scotland without austerity a Scotland
where pensioners are paid their fair
share where workers have fair and equal
pay a real living wage a Scotland where
all children are treated equally but our
health service is protected and valued a
nation that will be healthier wealthier
and happier mr. speaker the choice is
clear the United Kingdom is on a path to
self-destruction without a change of
course threats it will see an economy
smaller weaker
pruner Mark Carney from the Bank of
England said that brexit had already
cost each family six hundred phones
that's what's already happened and we
know that the hard brexit will cost each
household in Scotland sixteen hundred
pounds pushing struggling families to
the brink and already proof families
into destitution without single market
and customs union membership the future
relationship could only be FTA
introducing barriers to scottish
companies ability to trade this will
damage jobs investment productivity and
the earnings that will hit the most
disadvantaged in society harness as we
know mr. speaker that that people could
choose to live and work in this country
on these islands our net contributors
third economy if net migration is
reduced by a significant number we will
be purely economically and fiscally that
would be catastrophic
not just for workers but for our economy
mr. speaker after a decade of Tory
austerity our economy has already
suffered enough
the SNP will not stand by and allow the
UK government to raid roughshod over
Scotland's future this government must
go and it must go today but Mr Speaker
I've said it before and our First
Minister of Scotland has reiterated it
today
the only way for Scotland to protect its
interests
and for our nation to thrive mr. once
and forever be rid of this place and
instead be an independent nation in the
European Union or on account of the
level of demand a five-minute limit on
back bench speeches will now apply
sequester for choked mr. speaker when my
right honourable friend was winding up
the debate yesterday evening she said
that our country could ultimately make a
success of No Deal although of course
she was emphasizing that she didn't
believe that that was the best outcome
that was a course before the vote and
when we had the vote a few minutes later
then I think that the outcome of that
vote is one that the Prime Minister
certainly must respond to because the
feeling in this house 432 people and I
was one of them is that the Prime
Minister's deal however good she thinks
it is we regarded as a bad deal and and
I haven't heard anything for the Prime
Minister that implies that she accepts
the verdict of the house last night that
we regard her deal as a bad deal and the
Prime Minister was right 22-page as such
a scenario because in her Lancaster
House speech two years ago she feared
that the European Union would only offer
us a bad deal a punishment deal and as
she put it and she therefore emphasized
that no deer would be better than a bad
deal and she emphasized the benefits
that would come from a No Deal including
our ability to be able to trade freely
across the world our ability to be able
to enter into a new economic a model all
the benefits that would come from being
masters of our own destiny as an
independent nation and those were the
benefits of No Deal which she set out
obviously she like everybody else wanted
to get
good deal but as we have not got a good
deal I plead with my right honourable
friend to ensure that she doesn't close
the option of no deal and indeed she
intensifies the preparations for no deal
because that is the best way of
concentrating the minds of those in the
European Union that we are serious about
an alternative if you go into a
negotiation you say the only alternative
is to accept your deal or stay in the
European Union then what's going to
happen the European Union are holding us
to ransom on that what we need to be
saying is that we are confident and
believe in ourselves that we could be
able to make a really great success of
No Deal unfortunately that has not been
the negotiating stance of the Prime
Minister and her advisors and we are
suffering as a consequence of that last
Saturday mr. speaker I had a public
meeting in my constituency and it was
attended by over 200 people there was a
lot of anxiety expressed at that meeting
about whether or not the brexit that we
have been promised would actually be
delivered and it's great to hear the
Prime Minister reassessing her
commitment to deliver a brexit but if
she doesn't deliver that on the deal
that was rejected last night and then
how is she going to deliver it if she
rejects the No Deal alternative and my
constituents were very very worried
about the fact that they could see as
the referendum commitment to leaving the
European Union somehow being undermined
by the Prime Minister and by the
government and that in turn was
undermining their trust
I'll give way very quickly he's making a
compelling case that we should go back
to Europe and renegotiate he knows we're
at the end of the process time is
running out he also knows and I think
regrets that we're not ready for no deal
isn't he actually making a case then to
extend off 450 in order to get the right
deal that he will support no no I'm not
because two years ago we were told by
the prime minister that nothing was
agreed to everything was agreed and that
every
was going to be agreed within two years
and we now know that nothing ever has
been agreed effectively certainly so far
as a future relationship it is concerned
just trying to buy more time it's not
going to solve this problem what needs
to happen is that we need to leave the
European Union on the 29th of March and
then we can have negotiations following
on from that when we will be standing on
a level playing field able to stand up
our own interests and we will uphold the
European Union's
a bluff because what they're trying to
do is they're trying to undermine our
ability to be able to do what we want to
do in this situation you expect after if
you are unsuccessful in a in a conflict
that the victor will impose conditions
upon the vanquished what is happening
here is that European Union is seeking
to impose conditions upon us because we
have got the temerity to want to leave
the European Union that is wholly
unacceptable and the government's
negotiating position I think has been a
supine throw out okay if we go to no do
we will go immediately to default WTO
terms including tariffs for example on
lamb exporters of 40 percent silicon and
we won't have a trade bill it's not in
the past at the moment to available us
to even do anything about it does you
won't see there are serious risks in
that cage inside respond to all the
scare mongering and the is good at the
scam angry let's recall the fact that
our Prime Minister herself has said that
no deal is better than a bad deal the
House of Commons has said that this is a
bad deal you were there for why don't we
go mad on no deal and get on with it and
actually thereby deliver for the people
who's been resolved that they wanted in
the referendum and certainly Mike my
constituents are looking eagerly towards
the prospect of being able to have no
deal on the 29th of March I asked and
I'm not going to get ready well I asked
at the brexit committee I asked the
Secretary of State responsible for
leaving the European Union I asked of
what would happen on the air is father
on the 30th of March and it was conceded
that there wouldn't be any difference to
the current arrangements on the 30th of
March that is an example of the scare
mongering that's going on about
No Deal I regret that the government did
not prepare more actively and further in
advance for the No Deal option but now
we must not let the government benefit
from its own incompetence by saying we
don't think that we're ready for no deal
we should be ready for no deal on the
29th of March and that's why we need to
accelerate the preparations for it if
asked by my constituents mr. speaker if
they have confidence in the government
as their reply would be not a lot both a
heck of a lot more than in the labor
opposition and certainly they will have
for even more confidence in the
government if they are confident that
the government is not ruling out No Deal
is stepping up the preparations for no
deal and is able to confirm and
equivocally again that we will be
leaving the single market the customs
union and we won't be in a situation
where we have to have people coming into
our country without any control over our
borders you George how earth
mrs. figure it's a great pleasure to
follow the Honourable member the Christ
Church and I think he just demonstrated
why the Prime Minister's offer to reach
out to every section of the house every
section of opinion on Rexach isn't going
to work there is nothing the Prime
Minister could do that the Honourable
gentleman other than a hard brexit that
the honourable gentleman would accept
and that I think encapsulates part of
the problem that the Prime Minister has
to deal with in the prime minister's
statements to the house on Monday I
opened I said by that she had the real
problem that she had and the statement
she had made didn't alter the fact that
she had first of all no majority and
secondly because she had no majority no
authority and thirdly because she had no
authority she had a government
effectively were of no use to the
country as a whole I think I didn't
quite use those words but that's what it
amounted to I listened very carefully to
the Prime Minister over the in the
intervening periods and she is offered
nothing really
anyone could work with had she been in
the mode she was in following the vote
last night two years ago or even 18
months ago reaching out across the
chamber to different parties different
strands of opinions might have produced
something different that would have been
acceptable to the vast majority of
people I voted for article 50 like many
others in the hope that we would come up
with a brexit that would meet the
expectations and hopes of my
constituents the problem is that the
Prime Minister's deal didn't
do that and that's why we are now in the
position we're in now i there's been a
lot of comments about historical
precedence in terms of Parliament's and
how long it is since the government was
defeated by such a margin and I've
decided in a conversation and had last
night so I would look for other
historical precedents that once it went
about Parliament but were about treaties
or deals or bilateral agreements and I
came across this one mr. speaker and
it's the Treaty of Tordesillas
1494 and I think probably even the
Honourable member for North Somerset
would struggle with that one
it was a treaty effective between
between it's a treaty effectively
between Spain and Portugal which tried
to carve up the rest of Europe and Inter
and decide who would get which colonies
and guess what mr. speaker the rest of
Europe didn't agree with it and it was
eventually became defunct and never was
implemented and I rather think that the
Prime Minister's deal rather resembles
that treaty now the Prime Minister
fought the last general election on the
slogan we Britain needed a strong and
stable government well after last
night's events I mean we haven't had us
a stronger stable government since the
election but after last night's events
it certainly isn't strong and all the
speculation that's going on around
what's going to happen over the next few
weeks it certainly isn't stable and
that's why I think this folks have no
confidence is timely but also necessary
now I just want to take issue with
something the Prime Minister said in her
speech which I think I'm sure she meant
it sincerely but it doesn't represent
what is the reality of life on the
ground and in my constituency she said
in a speech that the government was in
justification file for why the
government wanted to go on that she was
fighting against poverty and inequality
now you know like it simply isn't true
my right honourable friend the leader of
the Opposition went through a long list
of problems of in terms of policy and
the delivery of public services what as
to why that's not sure I won't repeat
those but in my constituency this is
this is a government that's tremely
grateful to write on 10 I apologize for
interrupting him the opposition is very
considerably disadvantaged by the
malfunction of the timekeeping facility
yes I'm well aware of that
it's very need to stand up it is very
unsatisfactory unfortunately as I said
to the house I think yesterday those who
put it right cannot do so while the
house is sitting but it is
disadvantageous I can appeal to the
whips to try to keep members informed
and in deference to the seniority the
right honourable gentleman and in the
expectation that he's approaching his
pea ratio and I will happily allow him a
further sentence
George health I do appreciate it is
difficult I appreciate it's difficult
but members do know what the minute
situation is when they stand they might
not know the second situation but they
do know the minute situation mm thinking
you know I always try to satisfy the
demands you place on me and I will do so
now I just want to say that the prime
minister said the government was
fighting poverty and inequality she
might try telling that to the 8000 over
8,000 people in my constituency
see who had to resort to food bands last
year 3000 of which the parcels of which
were distributed were for children is
that a government that is fighting
poverty and inequality I think not and
it's a government that has run out of
ideas and run out of time you know I
appreciate read Hangul gentleman's
cooperation Neal Parrish it's a great
pleasure to speak in this debate I have
absolutely full confidence in this
government and I shall be voting against
motion tonight as I we've been recently
surveying canvassing in Axminster in
Seaton in Tiverton in Colombia and many
of my other tangs I am I am amazed at
the true support for the Prime Minister
out there on the street it really is
quite amazing they recognize that she is
a lady who has taken on an almost
impossible job mr. speaker to actually
fulfill the referendum result there was
a people's vote and that people's vote
took place in 2016 it was the largest
vote in a generation and there was a
clear majority to lead the European
Union and that is precisely what we must
do but what is interesting let's analyze
this wonderful vote that happened last
night there's actually analyzed how we
got to this massive figure of some 230
against because on one side you had a
number of people on the Labour benches
that don't come clean with the fact they
want to stop brexit altogether I do have
to pay tribute to the Liberal Democrats
and the Scottish mascius while I
disagree with them fundamentally but one
thing they do do is come out in the open
and actually say they are in favor of
remaining in the European Union but if
you want to deliver brexit it is a prime
minister that can actually do it so on
the one side we had people voting
because they want to thwart wrecks it on
the other side on my own side we have
people who wanted to make sure it was
the
this brexit ever those two lots of
people have absolutely nothing in common
as to speaker whatsoever because when
the leader of the Opposition I will in a
minute when the leader the opposition
stood up at the end and said of course
what we need now to do is stay in the
customs union immediately huge groans
from my own side because that's
precisely what they didn't actually want
to do
so therefore the Prime Minister has to
get this deal through now I very much
support the the Democratic Unionist and
the the border in in Northern Ireland to
make sure that the whole of the United
Kingdom is actually treated in the same
way so therefore there is work to be
done but does a hard brexit actually
help the Northern Ireland Irish
situation does it help food processing
does it help agriculture it certainly
does not because of huge terrorists
potentially and huge problems in the
border and I know very well and on the
island of Ireland there is always a huge
mix of processing from the pigs in the
north to the land and the South to the
milk going all the way round the isle
the island of Ireland so therefore let's
be absolutely sensible and and let's
decide to have brexit not go back to the
people's vote I will I will weigh though
you're okay right well you asked it you
asked it you asked to it de'vide he did
ask me to do just that yeah okay right
thank you Thank You mr. speaker I will
[Laughter]
it's an honor to uh to give my over
friend the opportunity to the next part
of a speech by intervening
what do you also agree with me that in
the light of the parliamentary
arithmetic last night on the boat and
the vote that we are faced with today
that it would be infinitely better in
this country to have the continued
leadership of a prime minister that has
the experience of negotiating so far
because it's only somebody with that
experience and that knowledge of the
detail that can in fact reach out
successfully across this house to try
and find a solution to this intractable
parish right because we have a prime
minister with the experience we have
actually a prime minister that has
actually stuck to her guns that's what
she is hugely criticized for the fact
that she has we've got a leader in the
opposition who actually can't work out
whether he's in favor of a referendum
another referendum and not he not quite
sure which way he would vote if there
was a second referendum and he also
doesn't know when if there wasn't to be
a general election whether the Labour
Party would take Britain out of the
European Union or keep them in so
therefore this is at this is a this is a
leader that would actually negotiate
with a European Union
certainly not it would never happen and
so therefore we need to actually deliver
and when I talks to the people in my own
constituency and all of you across this
house whatever party you do you do most
people think what on earth are we
getting so worked up about why haven't
we actually done it and for goodness
sake get on and do it and so why is it
that you know the Prime Minister is
wrong and this house is right because I
voted and campaign remain well I
actually accept the result of the
referendum but this this this house is
not representative in any shape or form
of the opinion of the people of this
country because people may have changed
a little bit you may have a second
referendum and it might turn out that
the result is 48% to leave and and and
52% to stay what does that cure
absolutely nothing let's have a third
referendum you know or let's have a
fourth referendum we have had a
referendum and we need to deliver that
and I say in all sincerity while I
disagree entirely with the opposition
and I disagree entirely with the
opposition for bringing forward this
motion what I do also say to my own side
clearly mr. speaker is that we are the
party of government we were elected to
govern this country and so therefore we
have to make a decision and we can't sit
here contemplating our navels forever as
to whether we are going to make a
decision or not because this idea that
you just drive us and drive us and
you'll get the hardest wrecks it
possible and it will just about destroy
British agriculture because I know that
the brexit ministers and others are just
waiting to pour cheap food into this
country because they will actually want
to see cheap food delivered under brexit
and that will hugely affect our farmers
so for goodness sake come together
there's always a party govern this
country properly and get a deal and get
out of the European Union thing